c'est une arme de dissuasion de la
police le cheval il est de toutes les
manifestations de toutes les émeutes on
dit qu'un cheval vont faire le travail
de dix policiers tentent en
cause l'efficacité
mais ce cheval de la police de montréal
n'est pas n'importe quel cheval c'est un
cheval canadien ça prend des gens avec
vivons caractère et tout le choix 15 et
représente un cheval qui fait fort qui
en durera qui peut patrouiller ou un
dante même façon pendant 7 8 heures à
avoir un cavalier ans celle qui va
rester calmes dans sa tête ce canadien a
derrière lui trois cent cinquante ans
d'histoire c'est un joyau du patrimoine
mais un joyau méconnu menacée
denis de mars et son épouse claude se
consacre à l'élevage du cheval canadien
leur mission le sauver de la disparition
comme l'angleterre ou le togo brède
comme l'espagnol retrouvera l'espagnol
le portugal le résultat nier les états
unis on le croirait aux assises ont
aussi le morgen nous on a notre cheval
canadien le cheval du pays et il faut
qu'on en soit fier il ne pèse pas lourd
dans le cheptel du canada sur près d'un
million de chevaux il n'y en a plus que
5 me quand on vient de la population
totale en bois de 5100 niveau qu'est un
danger denis de mars et son épouse
claude et quelques irréductibles sont
décidés à sauver le cheval canadien
et ils font leur part ils ont démarré
leur élevage il y a dix ans oui et
pénélope il possède six chevaux dont
trois bébés de moins d'un an
le cheval canadien on le doit au roi
soleil louis xiv aime les chevaux et
pour aider la colonie menacé il consent
en envoyant nouvelle france il les prend
à même ses écuries on croit qu'ils
proviennent de normandie ou du poitou un
premier groupe arrive en juillet 1665 12
juments et deux étalons
d'autres voyages suivront et au cours
des 12 années suivantes un total
d'environ 80 chevaux poseront les sabots
en nouvelle france
d'abord destiné aux nobles et aux
communautés religieuses les chevaux vont
se multiplier les habitants vont en
acquérir et un siècle plus tard ils sont
nombreux treize mille soit un cheval
pour cinq habitants dans la colonie
pendant 100 ans ce cheval se reproduit
en vase clos sans aucun croisement avec
d'autres races c'est ça qui a défini la
race la géographie le climat bien sûr
qui fait que maintenant le cheval à une
belle crinière tout fourni pour le
protéger par exemple des moustiques la
crinière et là que ce qui fait qu'il
s'est développé de façon très très seule
et très très pu pour affronter des
plaines pour affronter les montagnes le
boisé il ya développé des pieds très
large pour pouvoir marcher dans les
tourbières on pourrait dire qu'il est
devenu un produit du terroir il sera
surnommé le petit cheval de fer il
devient indispensable et il est
intimement liée au développement de la
nouvelle france montcalm chevauche un
canadien pour combattre l'invasion
britannique les américains l'adoptent et
on importe par milliers ils étaient très
prisés pour la diligence pour les routes
il avait un très bon système routier là
bas malheureusement la guerre de
sécession également en
où ap à peu près en 13 et 15 mille qui
ont été vendus aux américains pour cette
guerre là et puis qui songe à merveille
pour la première fois la race du cheval
canadien est menacée ont créé au québec
des fermes d'élevage pour la maintenir
mais la mécanisation aura le dernier mot
même louis si on ne réussira pas à
retenir le cheval canadien au coeur des
fermes québécoises
heureusement il reste encore quelques
irréductibles comme daniel lebeau qui
persistent à exploiter sa forêt avec une
paire de canadiens
des canadiens ces contacts passés dans
le bourg on verra comment de latanier
parlons
donc pouvoir la masse
citons la mairie d'auch failli être en
fait seulement le fond et obsèques
ben tu es sont isolés jake sully de
la force brute qui
veut toucher il veut toucher puis m6 va
être polluée taumoepeau mouchetés je
travaille lui fait part à ses différents
chaque
arrêt mais ils se font rares ces
irréductibles un point tel que la
demande pour des chevaux canadien a
presque disparu marie josée proulx en
sait quelque chose avec son conjoint
elle élève une cinquantaine de chevaux
surtout des canadiens présentement
l'offre est supérieure à la demande dans
quelques années le stade
le cheval canadien pourtant été reconnu
cheval patrimonial par le gouvernement
du québec en 1999 et celui du canada
trois ans plus tard la ville de montréal
s'apprête elle aussi à donner un coup de
main à l'occasion du 350e anniversaire
du cheval canadien la fondation même
d'un peuple et dans sa capacité de se
souvenir on verra dans nos rues l'été
prochain un artisan boulanger vendre ses
pains dans une charrette tirée par un
cheval canadien ses nombreuses qualités
lui confère une incroyable polyvalence
denis de mars travaille sur plusieurs
fronts à la demande de son association
de pièces de monnaie ont même été émise
cette année par le canada mais il faut
faire plus on essaie de développer avec
québec à cheval dans beaucoup de
circuits touristiques où les gens
peuvent faire avec un cheval sur une
période de 2 ou 3 jours avec un bed and
breakfast un hôtel auberge l'espoir
c'est que le rat survivent et prospèrent
pour y arriver denis de mars a un
objectif bien précis en tête il faut
qu'on en soit fier et on vise qu'à la
fin de 2015 au moins la moitié de la
population du québec savent ce que c'est
qu'un cheval canadien et que l'avenir de
ce petit cheval de fer soit autre chose
qu'une pièce en argent